the front runner in a presidential race
that's unlikely to be over for another
week cyprus's foreign minister Nicos
Cristo dolidis is ahead in the polls but
to win outright he'd need more than half
of the total vote something the same
polls suggests he's a long way short of
today is a celebration today is the day
for democracy every cypriot can with
their votes determine the future of our
country
early turnout was substantially up on
the previous presidential election in
2018 voters have much on their minds
soaring inflation irregular migration
deadlocked reunification books with the
Turkish north of the island and
long-running Corruption scandals
the main issue that concerns me is
corruption which I want to change with
my vote
and I call everyone to get off the couch
and come to vote the most important
thing for me in this election is the
direction the country is going to follow
to be pro-western
and not anything else Christo dilidis
who's largely been untainted in the
public eye by corruption is seen as
something of a continuity candidate
following the outgoing two-term
president Nicos anastasiadis of the 13
other candidates in the race two are
seen as realistic Rivals right-wing
party leader avarov neofitu and the
Diplomat Andreas mavrionis who's being
backed by the main leftist opposition
party
I have confidence in the Judgment of the
people I have confidence that with their
vote and their participation they will
lead our country towards better days
that judgment is expected to be split in
Sunday's round of voting the final one
likely to come in a two candidate runoff
in seven days time Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera